[Music]
this is actually real it's happening um
yes in the band I was like this is real
it's happening like we can finally start
rehearsals and everything and it's not a
secret anymore
right exactly you guys are probably so
excited to be able to tell people you're
fun you okay so if you had a chance to
dance together yet not really just play
your ass we've been playing around we
had a photo shoot we had about like 10
15 minutes and I was like Charlie's
Charlie's - yes yeah and so what has she
been like as a student so far so far
brilliant we can't wait to get started
then it's gonna be a fun season
she's like a dream partner what did you
think when you heard that sasha was in
your partner
we actually surprised each other I I met
him at his house but I didn't know whose
house it was and then I walked in that
way so that was super exciting he was
kids like my dream partner - I'm not
gonna lie I need the bedroom open I was
like blah okay so you have a little bit
dance experience a lot of people or say
the chimney kill it on the dance of the
stars floor and what do you think your
biggest biggest I mean issues would be
my feet turn out he's already on to me
about it she's a pigeon turd I'm not
gonna get told
they go straight but it's just like I'm
comfortable with them in like it's gonna
it's gonna be you know what this is one
of those shows where you know you grow
every week as a dancer already
I think this especially with Simone
she's gonna grow so much if we can week
out yeah
right the Simone I mean you're used to
performing in front of millions and
millions of people or you it is
something that like makes you nervous or
yeah like I got it I'm good no I'm so
nervous because you have to get out of
your comfort zones do things you're not
comfortable in dancing styles because
in-floor I train that all year round and
I'm comfortable with my dance and if I
say I don't want to do this I don't have
to do but this one's like you have to do
it
okay so nausea Luka and Ally Raisman
Laurie Hernandez of course have they
given you any advice any tips
well it's it got released today so they
didn't know I was doing it but Laurie
surprised me so I'll talk to her after
this do you think our biggest competitor
this season is going to be um I wouldn't
say ourselves but like growing together
that's the hardest part rather than
competing against other people
you